hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sister location
custom night we're going to be
attempting the golden freddy challenge
also known as 1020 mode the ultimate
challenge and sister location now I want
to say sorry for the long gap between
this and the last episode I know it's
been a while but there were things that
were out of my control I wanted to try
it before I left for the UK but I didn't
have time in terms of prep preparing
other videos and going and doing the
charity livestream and then coming back
with this horrible sickness that has
been with me for about a week now and
then also doing the 12 days of Christmas
it's all been a smorgasbord of work and
sickness and I really wanted to try this
before Scott made it easier and Scott
did make it easier by giving more power
during this specific night I'm going to
be doing this and thankfully considering
my voice is thrashed I will be able to
do this without talking and I'm going to
concentrate at this very hard and then
afterwards I'm going to talk to you guys
about my thoughts and strategies and
like thoughts about the story because
supposedly there's a hidden cutscene if
you beat this mode in the game and I'm
very eager to see it because I have not
seen it I have not looked up anything
else about this game I have not looked
up any strategies all I'm going into it
is with my strategies a little warm-up
on easy mode and that was easy mode it's
super easy it's literally everything's
at 3 it's super easy so that's no test I
just wanted to do that as a flexibility
test and to see if I remembered all the
mechanics but without further ado I'm
gonna be trying very hard mode and let's
see how long it takes it is currently
Tuesday December 20th
it is now 1236 p.m. I'm gonna let you
know the exact time that I am done ready
here we go
[Music]
hi it's now day 2 I still feel a little
sick but I feel a little better than I
did yesterday and I've got the basic
strategy down I've gotten very close uh
I've gotten so close and I just need to
adjust my strategy about foxy because
what I didn't realize is that foxy does
drain power when he hits the door so I
just need to make sure I watch foxy a
little more which requires some minor
adjustment but if I do that I shouldn't
have enough power no problem then this
should be in the bag but I just got to
make sure that my reaction times in my
concentration are up and that's a bit of
a struggle right now but I've almost got
it
so this should be it should be good hi
guys I just wanted to do kind of a
developer commentary about this because
once again I was too busy concentrating
to be able to talk while I'm playing and
I apologize because my voice is still
very raspy I'm still sick but I wanted
to kind of sift through the chaos here
because if you're watching this and this
is a very sloppy opening anyway so it
seems extra chaotic but to be perfectly
honest this particular 2020 2020 mode is
not that bad once you get the rhythm of
it and once you are able to pay
attention and focus on multiple
different things it actually turns into
an experience that is not too terribly
complicated because it is predictable
and when you have a predictability it
becomes easier and easier through
repetition now this was difficult
because my reaction times were lower
because I was sick but I'm not making
any excuses about it right I that anyone
would be able to do this if they had
enough focus so let me just go from top
to bottom in terms of the enemies
pay attention you may have noticed that
I'm saying left and right and and that's
just a reinforcement to know where
Freddy is because when he flips back and
forth it's easy to lose track of exactly
where he is
I double reinforce this by moving the
camera over to the side that he's on and
then I say it in my brain so I don't
forget and I say it every time that he
moves so I know this every time so then
I'm able to respond to his call out on
whether he's on the left or the right
side hmm so after that the second
responsibility is foxy you have to pay
attention to foxy and this is a lot like
five nights at Freddy's ones you have to
know where he is or you have to keep the
camera on him so he doesn't leave his
tent because when he bangs on the door
much like five nights at Freddy's one he
does drain your power now not as much as
he originally a me only drains like two
to three percent as far as I know but
it's important to pay attention to him
and keep track of him so he doesn't
leave his ten much and go bang on your
door a whole lot through the whole night
now this is difficult because the more
you flip up your screen the more you
have to risk looking at yendo and yendo
is probably the thing that makes this
the most difficult if yendo wasn't there
this would be so much easy because yendo
is like a reaction time test if you flip
the screen down and he's there you have
to flip the screen back up but there's
also a small chance I believe probably
like a thirty percent chance that he's
not there and if your finger is twitchy
you'll flip the screen back up and
that's what I mean by slop if you see me
flipping the screen spastically it's
because like they're right there it's
because I was stuck in a loop of
instantly twitching it back up until he
appeared and then I was able to break
out of the loop
from my own finger so he drains your
oxygen and he does it quickly so if
you're not instant-on bringing the
screen back up you're gonna lose oxygen
and then you're not going to be like to
see anything in the in
higher game and then your focus goes off
and this game or this particular mode is
broken down into three different senses
you have to see to be able to know a
little bit and you know on it and yendo
is there you have to be able to listen
to know when Freddie's doing this thing
when baby bats doing this thing when
Pelorus doing their thing and you have
to have muscle memory to know where to
put your mouse for the cameras and ferb
onyx knows so there's three different
things and if you remove the ability to
see then you're kind of your whole plan
starts to unravel not that it's
impossible but it is guesswork at that
point but after that yendo is the hard
one and then everything else kind of
falls into lips bonnet is just like can
you put your hand on it on nose it's
just kind of following your left you try
to keep your mouse at a same level on
the screen every time right your turn
back and I think I think thankfully it
defaults after you put the camera down
the mouse resets position to on its nose
level which makes it a lot easier and
then you just have to move it left next
up is Bowl or ax and below Aziz Laura
and bidi Bab kind of fall into the same
category you're just listening below
you're listening until she gets really
close bidi Bab you only need to listen
for the metal vent sound that she makes
when she's near your door when you hear
that crumpling of aluminum metal that
means that she's very nearby and you
just need to throw down that door until
you hear a bang you got to be careful
when you've got a lot of doors down
waiting for bangs until all the bangs
clear and then you can go and then the
next thing that you have to worry about
is in part and conjoined with flipping
up the screen for foxy rights
that's the electro Bab and the mini
arenas that are messing with your power
in your air so the thankfully and this
is where the pattern comes in they do go
not have it you can get them so they
sync up at the exact same time and then
you didn't take care of them both at
once and it makes my life a lot easier
because that's one or variable that I
don't have to watch out for it combines
two things into just one thing right so
you're technically only messing with
nine animatronics after that everything
starts to fall into place you know
you've got a little bit in the back and
that's
muscle memory to move over to the lol
keys let all this is like a balance of
oxygen not so much power because power
wasn't too big of an issue because I was
able to get through this with a few
percentage left but oxygen being able to
see above all else was the hardest thing
and towards the end here you can see
it's getting really dark very hard for
me to see and I I suppose you kind of
cheat your way around that you could
brighten your monitor really high you
could turn the gamma up really high on
your computer and maybe you could kind
of get through that but I I didn't want
to do that because it's not cheap and so
all in all this makes for a very
complicated experience you have to
multitask on a lot of things but it's
not impossible even though it seems like
it might be there's just a lot of moving
parts and a lot of things that you have
to pay attention to and there goes foxy
but thankfully I'm already at the end of
the road here and I have officially
wanted so thanks for listening
my
hurt I did it I'd rather it's me Michael
I did it I found it it was right where
you said it would be they were all there
they didn't recognize me at first but
then they thought I was you and I found
him I put her back together
just like you asked me to she's free now
but something is wrong with me and
she'll be dead but I'm not
I've been living in shadows there is
only one thing left for me to do now I'm
going to come find you
I'm going to come find you
[Music]
oh is that the next game I don't know
fazbear's fright I have no idea okay
that was an experience man I'm full of
pep adrenaline is coursing through my
veins okay so a few things about that um
when I I do think that it is probably
impossible to beat it beforehand because
the nights beforehand were seven minutes
and thirty seconds long this night is
six minutes long each hour is a minute
and therefore there's a minute and 30
seconds of extra time that you would
need to do to be able to beat it in its
previous incarnation or at least that's
what I'm assuming it is in terms of him
giving more power but in all honesty I
don't think that would have been
possible just because of how tight the
constraints were I was having so much
problem yesterday is because you have to
do these 20 20 modes you have to focus
for like six to eight minutes straight
depending on the game and I would say
this one's very hard but not like the
hardest I've ever done mostly because it
may seem complicated but everything in
this particular one has a rhythm see I
was able to combine the electro Bab and
the mini Rena in the one they were in a
set rhythm they would go off at exactly
the same time so I was always able to
predict that and for a long time I was
just letting foxy go because I didn't
think that foxy stole power like in five
nights at Freddy's one but she does so
as soon as I accounted for that I only
needed a few more tries and then I was
able to beat it because yesterday I
realized that towards the later end of
my attempts but I was starting to feel
so sick and I was just like coughing up
a bunch of phlegm and it wasn't good but
today I felt peppier not the worst I
would put it just before the first five
nights at Freddy's in terms of
difficulty oh no not that bad kind of
boring compared to the other ones in
terms of just the monotony of it because
this one is very monotonous because it's
the same thing coming at you again and
again and again and again you just got
to do the same thing over and over but I
would say a pretty good one not bad at
all and that cutscene is very
interesting because he said Father and
he thought I was you so did he
I gotta think about that I wish I could
watch again what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna watch it again then I'm gonna come
back and get get more thoughts about it
because I wasn't able to capture
everything but I'll I'll go look it up
in just a second be right back alright
so I just watched back to the UM I just
watched you back the cutscene and
there's a few interesting things to take
note of it uh number one the guy says
his name was Michael and number two he's
talking to his father and number three
he's talking to him telling him that he
shouldn't be alive now at the end of the
cutscene it showed up it showed probably
it showed the blown up wreckage of five
nights at Freddy's 3 after the
protagonist lights the [ __ ] on fire
and burns it all down and it was
revealed at the end of five nights at
Freddy's 3 that spring-trap did survive
that so I can only assume that from this
cutscene Michael Michael Afton who I'm
assuming that is because his father
they're all British the person at the
beginning of this game was mr. Afton and
I'm assuming that they're all the Afton
family and I'm even assuming that the
daughter who keeps talking to her father
asking to go see baby and was eventually
killed by baby was their daughter and
Michael's sister but all that aside it
showed Michael as spring-trap surviving
the explosion which we already knew for
five nights at Freddy's 3 but that vo
could have taken place at any time
throughout now there's been some
theories saying that there are two
purple guys and and I could understand
that in terms of like a father-son duo
there could be two purple guys in this
and just kind
having a powwow of murdering and
creating horrible monstrosity zuv death
and weird life and and you could kind of
see it in terms of the timeline now I
correct me if I'm wrong I might be wrong
about this timeline but I believe it
goes the oldest is five nights at
freddy's 4 which was 1983 or four in the
original fazbear's pizzaria fazbear's
fun time whatever it was called I
believe that was the original then and
in that you can see cutscenes of purple
guy not being a murderer but just
generally seeming like an employee
putting employees in suits of his
horrible creations now you go to sister
location where Michael is sent in by his
father to try to piece together what's
left of piece together what's left of
his sister and their daughter and I
can't help but be drawn to the
comparison of entered to the the puppet
from five nights at Freddy's 2 because
the puppet in the mini-games wanted to
piece the chilled the dead children back
together now to what end
I don't know but this creation whatever
it is entered somehow was able to give
Michael Afton near supernatural powers
of living beyond death when you should
not be alive he went in Michael's body
transformed him into literal purple guy
and then was exploded out now maybe that
happened to their father maybe that was
already the case I don't know it doesn't
seem possible because everyone in the
neighborhood was very intimidated by
this purple fellow by the name of
Michael Afton and purple guy walking
around the streets but it's all just
very confusing you know and I say
comparisons just by the button the mask
the three to four fingers the spiral leg
matching the spiral pattern of the
puppet like and the general marionette
nature of this creation here there's a
little bit of me and everybody pulling
the strings that's the only thing that I
could think
the master theorist I know a lot about
this but I don't know everything so
these are the only the conclusions that
I can draw so there may be two purple
guys this was Michael Afton his father
is mr. Afton and it's possible that his
sister was the girl that was killed by
baby and he was sent on a mission to try
to put her back together because his
father created literally created life in
these machines and somehow in a
perverted way maybe this purple guy who
got forced into spring-trap and was
haunted by the souls of dead children
was corrupted in a wrong way
turning life into something perverted by
something that is by itself
perverted life in this it's all very
complicated story or maybe it's
simplifying I have no idea I would love
to see a grand outline of everything
from top to bottom but I feel like we
are not quite there yet I feel like
there might be one more game going or
maybe not who honestly who knows but
this one sister location was really fun
I liked it it was a welcome change from
everything that I've seen thus far and
it really really hammer home the
interesting story behind everything and
I like that a lot and it was a pretty
good challenge in custom night if I I
don't know if I rank the difficulty but
I said five nights at Freddy's - five
nights at Freddy's 1 this game financed
ready for and then five nights at
Freddy's 3 that's what I'd say in terms
of difficulty for the 2020 modes but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]